[Music]
Oh JK Rowling what are you do with your
time give it all you added in charity
and I guess disjunctions fine fine
whatever you got to give it more Johnson
baby
crackling the paper to me don't really
consider it for charity I do it for the
[Music]
I'm giving you upsala creative freedom
write up a screenplay over frequent use
ago for Broadway and collaborate on a
comic with Joe sweet or a miniseries the
BBC and he that sounds good to me it
suggests oh my god you dig it
cancel you and after considering
this we're pretty careful if you don't
have a can
that would totally
damn dental I'll take it
[Music]
you
so you know that is the shortest song in
the album it's not an album full of
minute 30-second long songs it they're
mostly normal laying I do have a special
place in my heart for really short songs
so I really like that one but he was
made by Risa rude ill whose work you may
know from all of her amazing things that
she puts on tumblr and thank you to
Michael in seven who came over late last
night to help me with the dancing parts
I don't know how to use After Effects
incongruent is officially released it is
in the world now it's available on
iTunes and Google Play and Amazon and at
dftba records we can get physical copies
and also if you get a physical copy you
will get a download link just you get
them both ways unfortunately due to my
own idiocy the clean version is not
going to be shipping out of the
warehouse for another couple of weeks
yet sorry there was a mistake but they
will be signed if you pre-ordered them
we've also finished putting the entire
tour so you can now get tickets at every
single one of the stops including Pomona
which is nearby Los Angeles but not
quite Los Angeles San Francisco Eugene
Portland Seattle Boise Denver and Salt
Lake City I think I switched those last
year a couple of the venue's have
changed so make sure you check don't go
to the wrong place thank Ritu the
perfect strangers will also be playing
at VidCon God reminds me if you haven't
got your VidCon tickets yet you need to
do that right now because we're 95%
sold-out and I would love for his many
nerdfighters to be there as possible
because I like you if you aren't aware
of what VidCon is it's an annual meetup
of people who love online video with
concerts and panels and discussions of
the culture and business of online video
and performances and QAS and signings
and it's generally a really fun time
it's an Anaheim and it's from June 26 to
28 so three days of VidCon this year
guys super excited about it
I am also super overwhelmed by it but
that's life to people who don't live in
the western United States I'm sorry it's
hard to get away for more than a couple
weeks would you have scishow and crash
course and all the other projects and
people that we need to keep happy and
healthy here in Missoula
I like making those things for the
internet because everyone can have them
no matter where you live but if you are
in the western United States
lucky duck the rest of you I'm here
on the Internet always hope you like the
song John I'll see you on Tuesday
[Music]
you